my research lab sits about a mile from
where several bombs exploded during the
Boston Marathon in 2013 the surviving
bomber Dzhokhar tsarnaev of Chechnya was
tried convicted and sentenced to death
now when a jury has to make the decision
between life in prison and the death
penalty they base their decision largely
on whether or not the defendant feels
remorseful for his actions tsarnaev
spoke words of apology but when jurors
looked at his face all they saw was a
stone-faced stare now tsarnaev is guilty
there's no doubt about that
he murdered and maimed innocent people
and I'm not here to debate that my heart
goes out to all the people who suffered
but as a scientist I have to tell you
that jurors do not and cannot detect
remorse or any other emotion in anybody
ever neither can i and neither can you
and that's because emotions are not what
we think they are they are not
universally expressed and recognized
they are not hardwired brain reactions
that are uncontrollable we have
misunderstood the nature of emotion for
a very long time and understanding what
emotions really are have important
consequences for all of us I have
studied emotions as a scientist for the
past 25 years and in my lab we have
probed human faces by measuring
electrical signals that cause your
facial muscles to contract to make
facial expressions we have scrutinized
the human body and emotion we have
analyzed hundreds of physiology studies
involving thousands of test subjects
we've scanned hundreds of brains and
examined every brain imaging study on a
motion that has
and published in the past 20 years and
the results of these of all of this
research is overwhelmingly consistent it
may feel to you like your emotions are
hardwired and they just trigger and
happen to you but they don't you might
believe that your brain is pre-wired for
it with emotion circuits you know that
you're born with emotion circuits but
you're not in fact none of us in this
room have emotion circuits in our brain
in fact no brain on this planet contains
emotion circuits so what our emotions
really well strap and strap on your seat
belt because emotions are guesses they
are guesses that your brain constructs
in the moment where billions of brain
cells are working together and you have
more control over those guesses than you
might imagine that you do now if that
sounds preposterous to you or you know
kind of crazy I'm right there with you
because frankly if I hadn't seen the
evidence for myself decades of evidence
for myself I am fairly sure that I
wouldn't believe it either but the
bottom line is that emotions are not
built into your brain at birth they are
just built to see what I mean have a
look at this right now your brain is
working like crazy your neurons are
firing like mad trying to make meaning
out of this so that you see something
other than black and white blobs your
brain is sifting through a lifetime of
experience making thousands of guesses
at the same time weighing the
probabilities trying to answer the
question what is this most like not what
is it but what is this most like in my
past experience and this is all
happening in the blink of an eye now if
your brain is still struggling to find a
good match and you still see black and
white blobs
then you are in a state called
experiential blindness and I am going to
cure you of your blindness this is my
favorite part are you ready to be cured
alright here we go
alright so now many of you see a snake
and why is that because as your brain is
sifting through your past experience
there's new knowledge there the
knowledge that came from the photograph
and what's really cool is that that
knowledge which you just acquired
moments ago is changing how you
experience these blobs right now so your
brain is constructing the image of a
snake where there is no snake and this
kind of a hallucination is what
neuroscientists like me call predictions
predictions are basically the way your
brain works it's business as usual for
your brain predictions are the basis of
every experience that you have they are
the basis of every action that you take
in fact predictions are what allow you
to understand the words that I'm
speaking as they come out of my mouth
exactly predictions are primal right
they help us to make sense of the world
in a quick and efficient way so your
brain does not react to the world using
past experience your brain predicts and
constructs your experience of the world
the way that we see emotions and others
are deeply rooted in predictions right
so to us it feels like we just look at
someone's face and we just read the
emotion that's there in their facial
expressions the way that we would read
words on a page but actually under the
hood your brain is predicting it's using
past experience based on similar
situations to try to make meaning this
time you're not making meaning of blobbs
you're making meaning
facial movements like the curl of a lip
or the Rays of an eyebrow and that
stone-faced stare well that might be
someone who is a remorseless killer but
a stone-faced era might also mean that
someone is stoic ly accepting defeat
which is in fact what church and culture
prescribes for someone in da Carson Ives
situation so the lesson here is that
emotions that you seem to detect in
other people actually come in part from
what's inside your own head and this is
true in the courtroom but it's also true
in the classroom in the bedroom and in
the boardroom and so here's my concern
tech companies which shall remain
nameless well maybe not you know Google
Facebook are spending millions of
research dollars to build emotion
detection systems and they are
fundamentally asking the wrong question
because they're trying to detect
emotions in the face and the body but
emotions are in your face and body
physical movements have no intrinsic
emotional meaning we have to make them
meaningful a human or something else has
to connect them to the context and that
makes them meaningful that's how we know
that you know a smile might mean sadness
and a cry might mean happiness and a
stoic still face might mean that you are
angrily plotting the demise of your
enemy now if I haven't already you know
gone out on a limb I'll just edge out on
that limb a little further and tell you
that the way that you experience your
own emotion is exactly the same process
your brain is basically making
predictions guesses that it's
constructing in the moment with billions
of neurons working together
now your brain does come pre-wired to
make some feelings right simple feelings
that come from the physiology of your
body so when you're born you can make
feelings like calmness and agitation
excitement comfort discomfort but these
simple feelings are not emotions they're
actually with you every waking moment of
your life they are simple summaries of
what's going on inside your body kind of
like a barometer but they have very
little detail and you need that detail
to know what to do next what you do
about these feelings and so how does
your brain give you that detail well
that's what predictions are predictions
linked the sensations in your body that
give you these simple feelings with
what's going on around you in the world
so that you know what to do and
sometimes those though sometimes those
constructions are emotions so for
example if you were to walk into a
bakery your brain might predict that you
will encounter the delicious aroma of
freshly baked chocolate chip cookies I
know my brain would predict the
delicious aroma of freshly baked
chocolate cookies and our brains might
cause our stomachs to churn a little bit
to prepare for eating those cookies and
if we are correct if in fact some
cookies have just come out of the oven
then our brains will have constructed
hunger and we are prepared to munch down
those cookies and digest them in a very
efficient way meaning that we can eat a
lot of them which would be a really good
thing
you guys aren't not laughing enough I'm
totally serious it's really but here's
the thing that churning stomach if it
occurs in a different situation it can
have a completely different meaning so
if your brain were to predict a churning
stomach and say a hospital room while
you're waiting for test results then
your brain will be constructing dread or
worry or anxiety and it might cause you
to maybe
bring your hands or take a deep breath
or even cry my same physical sensations
same churning stomach different
experience and so the lesson here is
that emotions which seem to happen to
you are actually made by you you are not
at the mercy of mythical emotion
circuits which are buried deep inside
some ancient part of your brain you have
more control over your emotions than you
think you do I don't mean that you can
just snap your fingers and you know
change how you feel the way that you
would change your clothes but your brain
is wired so that if you change the
ingredients that your brain uses to make
a motion then you can transform your
emotional life so if you change those
ingredients today you're basically
teaching your brain how to predict
differently tomorrow and this is what I
call being the architect of your
experience so here's an example all of
us have had a nervous feeling before a
test right but some people experience
crippling anxiety before a test they
have test anxiety based on past
experiences of taking tests their brains
predict a hammering heartbeat sweaty
hands so much so that they are unable to
actually take the test
they don't perform well and sometimes
they not only feel courses but they
actually might fail college but here's
the thing
a hammering heartbeat is not necessarily
anxiety it could be that your body is
preparing to do battle and ace that test
or you know give a talk in front of
hundreds of people on a stage where
you're being filmed
I'm serious and research shows that
would students learn to make
determination right energize this kind
of energized determination instead of
anxiety they perform better on tests and
that determination seeds their brain to
predict differently in the future so
that they can get their butterflies
flying in formation and if they do that
often enough they not only can pass a
test but they will be it'll be easier
for them to pass their courses and they
might even finish college which has huge
which is a huge impact on their future
earning potential so I call this
emotional intelligence in action now you
can cultivate this emotional
intelligence yourself and use it in your
everyday life so just you know imagine
waking up in the morning I'm sure you've
had this experience I know I have you
know you wake up in the morning and as
you're emerging into consciousness you
feel this horrible dread you know this
like real wretchedness and immediately
your mind starts to race right you start
to think about all the crap that you
have to do at work and down that
mountain of email which you will never
dig yourself out of ever right and the
phone calls you have to return and that
important meeting that you have across
town and you're gonna have to fight
traffic to get there which means you're
gonna be late picking your kids up and
your dog is sick and what are you gonna
make for dinner and oh my god right what
is wrong with your life what's wrong
with my life
that mind racing is prediction your
brain is searching to find an
explanation for those sensations in your
body that you experience as wretched
like bread as wretchedness just like you
know you did with the blobby image so
your brain is trying to explain what
caused those sensations so that you know
what to do about them
but those sensations might not be an
indication that anything is wrong with
your life they might have a purely
physical cause maybe you're tired maybe
didn't sleep enough maybe you're hungry
maybe you're dehydrated the next time
that you feel intense distress ask
yourself could this have a purely
physical cause is it possible that you
can transform emotional suffering into
just mere physical discomfort now I am
NOT suggesting to you that you can just
perform a couple of Jedi mind tricks and
then like you know talk yourself out of
being depressed or anxious or or any
kind of serious condition but I am
telling you that you have more control
over your motions than you might imagine
and that you have the capacity to turn
down the dial on emotional suffering and
its consequences for your life by
learning how to construct your
experiences differently and all of us
can do this and with a little practice
we can get really good at it you know
like driving at first it takes a lot of
effort but eventually it becomes pretty
automatic now I don't know about you but
I find this to be a really empowering
and inspiring message and the fact that
it's backed up by decades of research
makes me also happy as a scientist but I
have to also warn you that it does come
with some fine print because more
control also means more responsibility
if you are not at the mercy of mythical
emotion circuits which are buried deep
inside
your brain somewhere and which trigger
automatically then who's responsible
who's responsible when you behave badly
you are not because you're culpable for
your emotions but because the actions
and the experiences that you make today
become your brain's predictions for
tomorrow sometimes we are responsible
for something not because we're to blame
but because we're the only ones who can
change it now responsibility is a big
word it's so big in fact that sometimes
people feel the need to resist the
scientific evidence that emotions are
built and not built in the idea that we
are responsible for our own emotions
seems you know very hard to swallow but
what I'm suggesting to you is you don't
have to choke on that idea you just take
a deep breath maybe get yourself a glass
of water if you need to and embrace it
embrace that responsibility because it
is the path to a healthier body a more
just and informed legal system and a
more flexible and potent emotional life
thank you
[Applause]